hey this is presto Walker I want to
start this video by sharing an email
hello presh I presented one of your math
questions to my maths teacher and he
couldn't solve it haha
before we go further in the email I want
to say thank you for showing your
teacher my video there are so many math
teachers that are watching mind your
decisions videos it's absolutely amazing
and I think we have the smartest
community of subscribers over all of
YouTube but it's no big deal if your
teacher could not solve the problem
admittedly I cannot solve a lot of these
puzzles either the fun part is learning
about heart problems learning the
problem solving techniques and then
using them to solve future puzzles so
back to the email instead he gave me
another one which I couldn't solve would
you mind having a look and maybe put it
out as a video the question is to solve
if the letters are distinct whole
numbers from one tonight the problem is
a a a plus b b b plus c c c equals b a
AC i want to think luke for sending me
this email can you figure it out give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for the solution
so how can we solve this addition
problem problems of this type usually
involve some guessing and checking so
let's try to limit the possibilities to
check the first thing we can do is
imagine we have the largest possible
values for a B and C this would be 9 99
+ 8 8 8 plus 7 7 7
this results in a sum of 2664 this is
the largest possible value for B AAC
what does that mean since it's less than
3000 and since B is not equal to 0 that
means there are only two possible values
for the digit B we could either have B
equals 2 or B equals 1 so now let's
further limit the number of
possibilities using what we've just
figured out we have two cases where B is
either equal to 1 or B is equal to 2 now
let's consider the sum in the unit's
column notice we have a plus 1 plus C is
equal to C in other words a plus 1 plus
C is equal to C plus 10 if we cancel out
the C we have that a plus 1 is equal to
10 this means that a is equal to 9
similarly in our other case we must have
a plus 2 plus C is equal to C which
means a plus 2 is equal to 10 and
therefore a is equal to 8 in this case
so we either have 9 99 plus 1 1 1 or 8 8
8 plus 2 2 2 so how can we figure out
the value of C well remember that the
largest possible sum was 2664 if we have
a equals 8 and B equals 2
we end up with the sum that's larger
than 2,800 but this is larger than the
largest possible sum we could have
therefore we cannot have a equals 8 and
B equals 2 so we can exclude this
possibility so we now know that a has to
equal 9 and B has to equal 1 if there
are any solutions so is there any value
of C that can make this possible well
let's add up what we know we have 999
plus 1 1 1 which equals 1110 the final
answer is 1990 C so if we take 1990 C
minus 1110 we end up with 880 C so that
the total reaches 1990 C by adding C CC
we must have C is equal to 8 so we put
that in and we end up with something
that works this is our answer
we have 999 plus 111 plus
888 equals 1998 did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description you can
also support me on patreon and you can
catch me on social media either at mind
your decisions or a presto Walker